tout d'abord ooh je suis tellement contente de
te voir à Londres aujourd'hui pour ce film un
super film réalisé par Hinari pour le
revenant tout d'abord j'aimerais
savoir que c'est un genre de projet que tu
cherches depuis longtemps tu veux  faire un
film comme celui-ci depuis longtemps, je
ne dirais pas que j'avais envie de faire un
film comme celui-ci, j'avais
certainement envie de voyager avec des réalisateurs
comme ala Hondo, je ne pense même pas
qu'Alejandro savait pourquoi  il voulait faire ce
film, c'était au début c'était un
scénario dont on avait parlé et qui
circulait mais personne ne voulait
s'en charger parce que sur le plan logistique, c'était si
difficile à faire d'être dans ces
éléments insensés de la nature et de nous immerger
dans le  beauté de la nature comme celle-ci, mais c'était
difficile pour un studio ou un cinéaste d'y
parvenir mais il y avait une faim qu'Alejandro
avait en vous, vous savez, vouloir
s'immerger dans un environnement et
voir ce que le monde naturel lui donnait et
je pense que je voulais  vivre cette
expérience avec lui, je voulais, je voulais
que le récit soit modifié par ce que
nous avons vu là-bas et c'est ce que nous avons fait,
toute l'histoire et toute la structure,
la poésie, les nuances et le genre
de voyage existentiel spirituel ont été
découverts.  sur place et sur place
varie selon le temps, juste après la combustion,
parce que brûler l'homme est tellement à l'intérieur, vous savez,
avec la pièce avec le théâtre, que celui-ci est
si extérieur avec le paysage
et quelque chose comme ça, je veux dire, whoa, c'était
oui, quelque chose d'étrange pour toi ouais
ouais  c'était un changement complètement, vous savez, à
180 degrés, mais les choses que j'ai faites m'ont
brûlé d'une certaine manière, j'ai pris certaines des
choses que j'en ai apprises et, vous
savez, j'ai essayé de les appliquer dans le récit
du revenant même quand c'était  absolument
différent par les raisons pour lesquelles vous avez dit que vous
savez que nous étions confrontés à des températures très basses, à des
altitudes élevées, à des
changements météorologiques énormes, à des chorégraphies massives et à
cette oraison crépusculaire infinie, vous
savez, le paysage des États-Unis et
en même temps une histoire émotionnelle très intime,
donc toutes ces choses rendent le
faux unique  et difficile comme l'enfer
peut-être que le premier personnage du film
est une nature, je veux dire, vous pouvez réagir avec
le lieu au Canada en Argentine avec
la nature ouais je pense donc je pense que
nous, vous savez, tout ce film était très
unique, nous avons répété pendant des mois
auparavant
chaque jour était un processus de répétition
parce qu'il voulait la beauté de la
lumière naturelle pendant cette heure et demie,
Chivo, l'un des plus grands
directeurs de la photographie, Bansky voulait exactement
tourner le film en entier et donc chaque jour
était une course folle pour accomplir
tout ce que nous pouvions  une heure et
demie donc ça nous permettait de connaître
beaucoup de spécificités sur ce qu'on devait faire
mais en même temps il y avait beaucoup de
tournage de films expérimentaux si on avait une
demi-heure supplémentaire on se précipitait souvent pour filmer
des aurores boréales ou  la beauté de vous
savez, un paysage entier fond
devant nous ou vous savez venir et
arriver sur le plateau et voir que le
monde entier avait été gelé la
nuit, ce sont toutes des choses que vous
connaissez, la beauté que vous ne pouvez pas pré-
Dans un film CGI, vous devez amener un
millier de personnes au milieu de la
forêt et y vivre pour pouvoir
filmer. L'ironie est qu'une grande partie
du monde naturel a été manipulée,
il était difficile de trouver des endroits qui
n'ont pas été touchés par l'homme.  comme ça la
nature est un personnage ici ses
paysages le menacent, le guérissent, le tuent
donc je veux capturer ce
sentiment épique mais en même temps toujours en
temps réel sur un temps fragmenté pour avoir le
point de vue du personnage et mettre
le public dans l'ambiance  les chaussures de ce type
à travers un plan très rapproché de son
visage et voir quoi donc tout ce langage
pour passer de ces paysages immenses à
ces moments émotionnels intimes c'était
la grammaire visuelle que je voulais
explorer et difficile mais ça vaut le coup
tu fais des recherches pour préparer ton
personnage je veux dire tu as lu un livre à
ce moment de la visite ouais c'était
important pour toi ou pas vraiment non non il y a
beaucoup de recherches mais
une fois là-bas j'ai dû en quelque sorte
oublier tout ce que tu sais  la recherche
était intéressante parce que même si nous
n'avions pas beaucoup de contexte historique
sur cette période, c'était une époque de l'
histoire américaine où l'Est a
commencé à infiltrer l'Ouest, le
capitalisme a déferlé vers l'Ouest pour
extraire les ressources, vous savez, tuer tous
les animaux coupés  les arbres déplacent
les Amérindiens mais rien de tout
cela n'était vraiment documenté c'était le Far
West c'était un
paysage intact il n'y avait pas de
système de gouvernement il y avait le français
anglais vous savez c'était les
Amérindiens tous dans ce creuset en
quelque sorte  pour survivre dans cette période il faut
comprendre que le melting pot était
très compliqué il y avait tous les
Amérindiens qui possédaient cette terre là-bas
étaient des Népalais Oh Mana Party vous avez
vendu une Louisiane et une énorme partie des
terres des Etats-Unis donc il y avait
beaucoup de Français, des Français, des Anglais, des
Français et beaucoup de
Canadiens qui mangeaient ça, donc c'était des Mexicains dont
nous dépendions. J'ai fait l'
indépendance de l'Espagne un an avant
deux ans avant, donc c'était un
melting-pot et et et je pense  J'étais
très intéressé de découvrir les origines de
cette histoire de colonisation où les
races mixtes commencent aux États-Unis, donc une grande partie
de la recherche provenait de journaux de
trappeurs de fourrures. Il n'y avait aucun écrivain là-bas
documentant l'histoire des
peuples autochtones, c'était avant toute
histoire.  cette région d'Amérique, donc
nous ne le savions pas, c'était comme
recréer de la science-fiction à partir de petits
extraits de journaux et et bien sûr, vous
savez, travailler avec des survivants pour
comprendre comment ces hommes ont enduré ces
paysages difficiles était l'une des principales
choses que je voulais  fais maintenant
les films absolument incroyables et la
séquence du macabre c'est absolument
incroyable J'ai joué cette séquence je
veux dire comme une chorégraphie c'était très
précis avec Grizzly et c'est brutal ou
alors le Grizzly a vécu une partie du
plan d'ouverture certaines séquences étaient
littéralement des semaines de répétition  Alejandra
ne veut pas que je parle de la façon dont cela a été
fait parce qu'il ne veut pas que je gâche
la magie, mais cela avait à voir avec
des câbles, vous savez, et des choses que vous
n'auriez jamais imaginées si simplement, si réelles, ce
n'était qu'une séquence.  c'est incroyable, c'est cette
planification intense qui, je pense, a créé
cette réalité que vous savez, c'est que c'était
beaucoup de réflexion dans chacune
de ces séquences, vous savez, pour le
réalisateur, comme si c'était aussi une
expérience unique oui, je me considère comme un
terminal  étudiant en art, vous savez, je pense que le
cinéma permet d'une certaine manière d'explorer des
possibilités infinies d'expression et de transmettre
des idées ou des émotions et vous savez à chaque
fois que s'il correspond vraiment à la
tension dramatique nécessaire, l'
histoire la rend meilleure ou plus puissante si
je peux  utilisez ces éléments pour essayer et
j'aime la possibilité d'échouer, vous savez,
même si nous ne pouvons pas échouer, alors c'est
ennuyeux cette partie du processus dans la façon dont
vous travaillez avec le contrôle sur celui-ci, vivez
dans chaque - très bien
pour être honnête, je pense qu'il est il est  un
réalisateur très exigeant et spécifique et
tous ceux que vous connaissez sans relâche pour
réaliser leur vision. J'adore, je veux dire
que vous feriez n'importe quoi pour ce réalisateur
et je pense que tous les acteurs ont ressenti
cela comme si nous créions une
œuvre d'art tout à fait unique.  si nous étions mis
au défi de faire quelque chose de très
différent de ce qu'on avait alors, je pense que nous avons déjà
vécu une expérience artistique, donc vous savez qu'il n'y
avait presque rien que nous ne ferions pas
pour lui parce que voulez-vous faire partie
de cette
expérience, vous savez, et c'était  excitant
pour tout le monde,
ce film était très physique, très extrême
pour que les acteurs se mettent dans
ces conditions en jouant avec un
très haut niveau et en
chorégraphiant méticuleusement rien n'était improvisé donc c'était
une chose pré-conçue une danse de tango
entre la caméra et elle partait
et  tout ce que nous prévoyons mais en même
temps pour être vrai et et dans des
endroits extérieurs très très inconfortables et cela
nécessite une âme de chœur courageuse au-delà de l'
incroyable métier que Leo a, vous savez,
vous travaillez beaucoup avec la pièce aussi avec Shiva
parce que j'aime tellement  beaucoup de cette séquence
avec moi peut voir tes briefs ouais tu peux
voir beaucoup de choses nous savons que tu étais le
directeur de la photographie peut-être comme d'
habitude parce que c'est si important sur
celui-ci ouais ouais c'était comme si je l'appelais tu
sais comme utiliser une montre suisse  chaque
jour parce que chaque département
devait travailler en coordination exacte avec Chivo
et cette caméra, il n'y avait qu'un seul homme, cette
caméra et les éléments, mais ce qu'ils
font cinématographiquement ici, je pense que
quelque chose est très unique, ils ont la
capacité d'apporter une vous savez  un
paysage épique de type David Lean et mélangez-le
avec une incroyable intimité de la respiration
et la sensation des battements de cœur d'un personnage,
puis tournez-vous vers quelque chose qui
ressemble à un plan de Tarkovski ou ou vous savez, vous
connaissez une sorte de beau
film européen que vous  c'est tout ce que vous savez
immerger ensemble dans ce
type d'expérience de réalité virtuelle et les chivos sont capables de
le faire, nous avons donc dû travailler avec Chivo très
spécifiquement, vous savez, une centaine de figurants
devaient travailler à l'unisson exact, le gros plan
de l'œil pendant qu'il fouettait  autour c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
une grande
réussite cinématographique à mon avis ce qu'ils ont
réussi ici et c'était et c'est
quelque chose qu'Alejandro
développe depuis longtemps et sa
mienne, je pense qu'il est vraiment en train de se
concrétiser en ce moment, est l'un des  les maîtres
cinéastes de notre époque
ambitionnent toujours que ce film ressemble plus à Birdman qui
a beaucoup à voir avec le jazz, vous voyez ce que je veux
dire, je pense que ce film doit faire beaucoup
plus avec la peinture et les rêves, vous savez, je
veux que ce soit une peinture sonore comme  si vous
pouvez entrer dans le tableau, j'imagine
toujours le Caravage et entrer soudainement dans
l'histoire et les germes de la
colonisation des États-Unis et être
un fantôme et l'esprit du temps flottant,
c'est comme ça que je veux que les gens fassent pour
obtenir sensoriellement ce film  vous savez, très
sensoriel, très inconscient, pas
réaliste mais dans bien plus, je pense que la
façon dont nous percevons ou avons la mémoire de la
réalité, vous savez, le grand
film de survie, c'est aussi que vous avez eu un grand
film d'aventure et bien sûr il
ne serait pas considéré dans  la nature donne un
lien varié en ce moment avec ce
sujet c'est un 19ème siècle bien sûr
mais vous pensez qu'une résonance très certaine
fera écho avec en ce moment absolument nous avons
fait un film pour nous immerger dans
la nature et voir ce que la nature nous a dit et
ce que la nature nous a dit était c'est  en changeant,
vous savez, nous avons dû arrêter la production à
deux reprises en raison du fait que l'
ensemble du paysage présentait des
conditions météorologiques sans précédent qui ne s'étaient jamais produites
et dans cette province du Canada et
cela se produit partout dans le monde et
c'est terrifiant que 2015 soit l'année la plus chaude jamais
enregistrée  l'histoire
bat des records tous les mois, nous en faisons l'expérience
directe dans ce film, nous avons dû l'
arrêter parce qu'il fut un temps où il y
avait toujours de la neige pour l'
histoire enregistrée, nous étions assis là sans
neige pendant des semaines et des semaines et des semaines et
c'était effrayant pour la communauté mondiale.  se
réveiller parce que c'est absolument étrange
que 2015 se soit déroulé ainsi, tout se
passe en ce moment,
il sait jusqu'où je suis venu pour les trouver,
donc tu as gagné trois Oscars l'année dernière avec
Burn Man en tant que réalisateur, comme meilleur film,
tu as 12 nominations cette année  qu'est-ce que
cela signifie pour vous, je veux dire, avoir 12
nominations pour ce film. Je suis très
fier que la plupart des départements principaux
de l'équipe aient été nominés. C'est essentiellement
une appréciation de la part des membres de l'Académie et de
certains collègues qui, d'une certaine manière, ont
été proches du processus.  de faire un
film qui apprécie ce que nous avons fait, vous le
savez et et cela fait du bien parce que d'
une certaine manière, nous avons pris beaucoup de risques, cela
aidera le film à créer une certaine
prise de conscience dans le monde et plus de
gens pourront le voir, c'est
finalement ce que  vraiment, ces récompenses sont
là et c'est une justification pour
nous de prendre un verre ensemble et d'être bien
habillés et de ne pas sentir la bière donc
ce sera drôle de nous voir propres en train de prendre
un verre et vous savez célébrer cette
nuit-là, ce serait génial la dernière  année
tu as le temps je veux être heureux
avec tes trois tes deux Oscars je veux dire - pour
plaisanter - pas parce que tu as fait la course
en même temps si je me souviens bien, je bois
juste après les cérémonies des Oscars l'
année dernière non ouais non j'étais  J'étais en train de
tourner ouais, je tournais quoi pendant que
tout cela se passait, j'ai commencé à tourner
ce film en septembre de l'année dernière, il n'y a pas deux
ans, mais c'était essentiellement pendant cette
saison de récompenses indépendantes, donc j'allais le faire. Je me
souviens de la soirée des Oscars, j'ai reçu
beaucoup de  mauvaise nouvelle de la production donc
c'était un sentiment très étrange de
contradiction d'être récompensé et en
même temps vous savez souffrir beaucoup de
problèmes en production donc mais c'était
génial c'était génial parce que ça me gardait l'
esprit pas dans la folie du  récompenser
les saisons et l'ego et des choses comme ça mais
garder mon esprit beaucoup plus inquiet de ce que je
faisais qui était très sain as-tu
un nouveau projet en ce moment dors
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup